a timely reminder welcome everyone to a
I my name is Jeff eisenach I'm a
visiting scholar here and I'm delighted
to welcome everyone to today's
discussion with the European Union's
commissioner for competition Margaret of
Astaire before introducing Commissioner
of Astaire I'd like to note that we have
probably several luminaries in the room
today but in particular ambassador of
the European Union to the United States
David O'Sullivan is here I wanted to
welcome ambassador O'Sullivan and thank
him for being here on a procedural note
our program will begin today with
remarks from Commissioner of Astaire
after that she's agreed to take some
questions I'll ask the first few and
then we will open it up to the audience
when we do we'll ask that you wait for
the microphone and that you state your
name and your affiliation before asking
your question now it's a great honor for
us to have Commissioner of Astaire with
us today as she's a native of Denmark
and has served in very senior positions
in the in the Danish government
including as Minister of Education from
1998 through 2001 Minister for Economic
Affairs in the interior from 2011 to
2014 she was political leader of the
Danish social Liberal Party and
ambassador of a Sullivan and I were
talking about those words have somewhat
different meanings in Denmark maybe than
they do here but she was political
leader of the Danish social Liberal
Party from 2007 to 2014 and it's my
understanding that she has served as the
role model for the protagonist of a
popular Danish television series about
the election of the country's first
female prime minister so she's not prime
minister but someone plays one based on
her on television in Brussels she served
as president of the economic and
financial Council also known as echo fen
in 2012 and in October 14 in 2014 she
was confirmed by the European
as commissioner for competition since
then she has been responsible for some
of the largest and most significant
antitrust actions in the history of the
European Union well not all of these and
indeed the majority have not involved US
companies certainly the ones that have
gotten the most attention on this side
of the Atlantic have including the abuse
of dominance finding against Google
earlier this year resulting in a fine
the largest antitrust fine in European
Union history of 2.7 billion dollars and
her 2016 finding that Ireland's tax
treatment of Apple has violated the
--use prohibitions against state aid
meaning that Apple owes currently 14
billion dollars in back taxes now
actions like these have won praise from
some and criticism from others here at
AEI we are committed to free enterprise
and competitive markets including
competition in the marketplace of ideas
and with that in mind it's an honor to
welcome Commissioner of astaire to the
American Enterprise Institute we look
forward to your remarks
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen it is it's a great
pleasure to be here
and I knew I'd feel welcome and it's not
only because of of the very sort of
Danish way my name was pronounced which
is actually quite rare I can tell you
this but also that this institute has a
motto the competition of ideas is
fundamental to a free society and for me
this is what policymaking is all about
if our ideas are never challenged
they'll never get any better we're not
stuck with ideas that once served as
well but haven't kept up with changes in
our world and our societies and when we
don't hear different views well I think
also we lose the freedom to think for
ourselves and just as competition of
ideas is fundamental to a free society
competition in our markets is
fundamental to a fair one because
challenges and competition makes us
better if businesses aren't challenged
if they don't have to compete well they
don't have any reason to work better to
serve people better competition is that
motor that actually drives businesses to
do better for consumers to cut prices to
offer more choice to produce innovative
products competition in for the
enforcers didn't built that motor we
just helped to keep it running running
smoothly
by getting rid of the obstacles that may
stop competition from doing its work and
this is why antitrust rules prevents
cartels stop dominant companies misusing
their powers to drive out competitors
this is why we have rules to make sure
that mergers do not undermine
competition and this is also why now
more than 60 years ago when the European
Union was founded we were given rules on
state aid to stop governments using
subsidies to give some companies and
unfair benefits and therefore unravelled
the level playing field the most basic
aim of competition rules is that of
keeping prices down in the past's five
years more than half of antitrust
decisions has been about putting a stop
to cartels like our idea decision last
year to find five European truck makers
a total of nearly three billion euros
for a cartel that fixed gross this
prices of trucks for 14 years most of
our work on merges is also about keeping
prices down in more than 90% of the
mergers that we have to step into the
last year and the year before
our main concern or that the merger
would have meant fewer fewer competitors
and higher prices and that makes real
difference in those two years our
estimate is that the work on mergers and
cartels have saved customers as much as
30 billion euros and that is without
ever considering the mergers
that were never filed all the cartels
that were never formed because our rules
wouldn't have allowed for it but there
is more to competition than keeping
prices down even when a product seems to
be free like a search engine or a social
network competition still helps to get
consumers a better deal last year we
looked at Microsoft's murder with
LinkedIn and even though most people use
LinkedIn without paying for it at least
in cash we were concerned that the
merger would affect competition we knew
that the merger after the merger the two
companies would connect their products
and that would have risked shutting down
other professional social networks of
the European market without competition
user would have lost choice they could
have lost for example the chance to
choose another service or a service with
the best privacy policy so we only
approved a merger after Microsoft gave
us commitment that it will keep the
market open also after the murder
competition gives us more choice and
lower prices today but it also helps us
to get better products tomorrow because
competition the drive to get ahead of
your competitors that pushes businesses
to keep innovating earlier this year we
found that the merger between dove and
Newcombe would not just raise prices but
also hold back innovation dove and
DuPont were two of just five
companies that took part in all stages
of developing pesticides to meet the
needs of farmer throughout the world and
we found evidence that they plan to cut
back on their research after the merger
that would have slowed innovation it
would have left farmers stuck with older
products that may have been less
effective and more toxic so we only
approved the merger after companies
agreed to sell a large part of the post
pesticides business including the world
wide research arm for pesticides
generation was also an issue in our
decision against Google earlier this
year consumers don't pay to use Google's
search engine not in cash at least but
that doesn't change the fact that search
of the Internet is a market and it is
one in which Google is dominant in
Europe with more than 90 percent market
share in most European countries market
dominance gives a special responsibility
a special responsibility under European
competition law and this is a
responsibility not to abuse the power
but to keep competition only on the
merits of products and services anyway
in our decision we established that
Google did not comply with this
obligation instead Google decided to use
its power as a search engine to deny
other companies a chance to compete on
neighboring markets
namely the market for shopping
comparison Google showed its own
comparison shopping service at the
top of the first page of search results
and that gave its own services a
prominence that its competitors could
match and google also demoted its rival
services in search result so that they
only appears on average on page four and
just go through your recent behavior
when you have done a search on the
Internet how often did you get to page
four I see no ray Stantz the results
were effect four impressive Google's
rivals suddenly lost as much as 90
percent of their traffic and despite
their best efforts they never got all
these visitors back and that matters not
because we feel sorry for those
competitors after all for a competition
to do its job well companies have to be
able to lose as well as win but that's
cut both ways
big companies also have to face
competition to face the risk of failure
and that won't happen if we allow them
to use their power to stop anyone else
from having the chance to compete
because when companies can't lose they
cannot do better either
of course and this is obvious I'm sorry
to waste your time saying this it is not
the job of a competition authority to
take the place of the markets to set the
prices of truck to tell Google or love
that innovation is important and what it
can produce but we know that as long as
competition stay fierce those companies
will have no choice but to meet
consumers needs to keep prices low to
make an effort to innovate and there is
no need for us to interfere in that
process by trying to say precisely what
should be the outcome of competition but
there are times when public authorities
as such need to go further when it does
make sense to control what the market
produces when our health or our
environment or our basic rights are in
question these are important concerns
but they are not something that
competition rules can fix not because
there is a problem with our competition
rules but because competition is only
part of the answer look at pesticides
for example farmers they need affordable
innovative pesticides and competitive
markets can answer that so by protecting
competition our decisions on the merger
between Dove and DuPont will keep prices
down and innovation thriving and we will
take the same approach when we look at
the merger the planned merger between
buyer and Monsanto
but prices are innovation are not the
only things that matter
I've had many letters postcards emails
tweets from people who are concerned
about these chemical mergers sometimes I
worry about prizes and innovation but
ever so often they are worried about
what pesticides can do to the
environment or to our health or the
safety of our food and I agree that we
cannot just rely on the market to
guarantee that pesticides are safe for
the farmers for environment for us as
consumers we need the protection of
clear and strict regulation Europe has
some of the world's most stringent
pesticide regulations in the world those
regulation applied before the murders
and they will still apply after the
mergers no matter what form they may be
competed in both to the companies that
merge and to companies that do not merge
but we shouldn't mix things up my job as
a European Commissioner for competition
is to look at how a merger will effect
exactly competition and that is what I
will do with my teams controlling
vehicle emissions is another case where
a competition law enforcement is not
enough understandably many people are
concerned about how their lifestyle
affects the environment and through the
market they can put a lot of pressure on
companies to innovate and to produce
greener products
and if company is a sort of answers or
response to that pressure by working
together to resist the demands for
greener products then competition and
forces may have to step in and that's
what happened in this truck makers
cartel I just told you about because the
other side of it was not only the
coordination of across this crisis it
was also that its members coordinated
the introduction of greener technology
so that none of them would bring the new
technology to the market before they
were forced to do that but we cannot
just rely on the markets to protect the
environment
we still need rules for vehicle
emissions that protect our health and
our climate and we need regulators who
can punish companies that break those
rules but it is for them competition and
enforcement is a bit of a paradox our
job is to help Marcus work better and
more freely but to do that we need to
interfere in the market and that is of
course a paradox and in it makes the
work a delicate balance
we shouldn't step in when competition is
not really threatened we should block a
merger for example that would cut costs
for consumers but it is just as
important that we do not look away when
we see something happening that does
harm competition either way if we get it
wrong consumers will suffer so what can
we do and this will be the end because I
would like of course to make a bow
because I think the good thing to do is
to look at the motto of this institute
by making sure
also our our ideas of competition are
open to competition we can exchange idea
with experts both in Europe and further
away and in fact we do just not all the
time we do it through organizations like
the international competition Network
which bring together more than a hundred
authorities from all over the world
including the Federal Trade Commission
and Department of Justice and that
network helps us to discuss some of the
trickiest issues of competition
enforcement and it helps us to reach
common ground as we did in 2014 as an
example when we agreed on recommended
practices on predatory pricing we also
exchanged ideas about cases since the
start last year we worked with US
authorities on more than 20 different
mergers like the merger between a B
improve and SABMiller the two the
world's two largest be approvers or they
can China takeover of Syngenta we've
discussed things like how these verjus
might harm consumers and what could be
done better to restore competition and
that cooperation and those discussions
has helped us to protect consumers
better being open to new ideas is maybe
more important now than ever because our
markets are going through enormous
changes some of those changes are about
technology algorithms are taking over
decisions from people including
decisions on the prices that companies
charge big data it's also a big helper
to cut costs and improve services which
kids could mean that companies without
that data
struggle to compete meanwhile some
markets are showing signs of becoming
more concentrators with fewer bigger
companies even if so far
Europe's in Europe those signs are
limited to a few industries in certain
countries so we need to discuss these
issues now when we can still adapt and
that is why I'm looking to set up a
panel of experts from outside the
Commission to advise us on how these
changes will affect consumers and how a
competition enforcement should respond
because even though our world is
changing I think it is clear that
competition rules still matter for many
many years to come
competitive markets will still be the
best way to meet consumers needs low
prices wide joyous innovative products
for tomorrow and to make sure that
markets work we need competition rules
to be enforced applying those rules in
practice what gets any easier but we
don't have a choice
competition in the market is as
fundamental to a fair society as
competition of ideas is to a free one
and I think that is as true today it is
has ever been thank you
[Applause]
well you've covered a lot of ground and
I want to spend a couple of minutes just
drilling down on some of these corn
antitrust issues and let me start with a
with a quote kind of frame very famous
in American antitrust jurisprudence from
I think the judge would the best name of
all time learned hand somehow never made
it onto the Supreme Court but Judge he
had a very famous appeals court judge
wrote that it was very important that
antitrust not punish these successful
competitors the firm which by virtue of
its expertise it's hard work it's
entrepreneurship is successful in
capturing the market and and as judge
Ham said the successful competitor
having been urged to compete must not be
turned upon when he wins so as as you
think about the problem this isn't
that's an old quote and this is an old
problem instead of quotes from 1945 as
you think about that and you think about
the googles of the world and the
Facebook's of the world who aren't
questionably have won the race what are
the how do you distinguish between
conduct which is harmful to consumers
and harmful to competition as opposed to
conduct which is simply harming the
unsuccessful the less the firm's
producing less value who haven't been as
entrepreneurial or successful in in the
race well this is exactly the balance
yes to make sure that you get the right
distinctions in Europe we have no we
have no ban on monopolies you more than
welcome to grow one yourself you can't
buy one but you can grow one if if you
have products that people like and they
keep coming then you can keep growing
the only thing is that when you then
because of your virtues of your products
become dumb
then you get a special responsibility
because it is quite obvious that
competition suffers if you yourself hold
like 90% of the market so you get this
responsibility not to misuse your muscle
and and this is exactly the thing you
can grow you can grow big
we will congratulate you all the way but
congratulations stops if we find that
you start misusing your position and
this is of course what we will have to
be tested on in in courts because this
is exactly the case of the Google case
well so also the Intel case so last week
in 2009 the Commission found Intel in
violation of the abuse of dominance
rules by virtue of giving rebates to
some of its customers in a way that was
alleged to drive out competition and
last week the European Court of Justice
remanded that decision it's been through
the courts now in a couple of rounds of
appeal remanded the decision back to a
lower court and as I read fully read the
decision but as I understand it on the
grounds that neither the Commission nor
the courts the lower courts had given
sufficient account to the question of
whether indulge Intel's conduct would
harm an equally efficient competitors so
that's a that's a standard which is yeah
very much part of American jurisprudence
do you see that decision having an
effect on first of all how do you see
that decision as it affects the Intel
matter to the extent you can talk about
it and and then do you see that decision
affecting other matters under way Google
Qualcomm and so forth well it's it's
hard to have an opinion something that
is undecided right because basically the
the European Court of Justice said to
the general course you have to redo your
work you have to look into the substance
once again and the rest of us will have
to of course respectfully wait and see
what comes out of this in the meantime
obviously we have work to do and we have
also of
developed working methods and line of
thinking sends Intel decision back in
2009 so we will keep working our cases
and I think it is important also to
recognize that most cases they will be
looked at from both size but from the
side of what's the effect and what's the
object of the behavior the two other
respects of the case of one of
jurisdiction was a very clear win for
the Commission and the third one will
sort of keep us in sort of thinking mode
for some time because it was a question
of how a meeting with the witness was
being recorded it had no influence on
the concrete case we have changed
procedures since then but the court
still gave gave us guidance as how to do
this looking forward and that of course
we will respect them and try to follow
that guidance okay the so I'm sure there
are real limits on what you want to say
or can say but just with respect to
Google because obviously there's a lot
of interest I think we have not had the
full written decision released yet is
that unless it's been very recent so
when do you when when will we see
because there are a lot of people
looking forward to reading it and and
then just for people who are not
following this as closely maybe can you
talk a little bit about the concerns
with the Android and Adsense and what
those investigations entail yeah we
really do our best to try to make our
decisions public as fast as possible but
that of course had to respect that they
can be concerns of business
confidentiality so we have to clear the
decisions first and that takes the time
it takes but that we make a priority
after the decision has been taken
because as you say a lot of people would
like to read the decisions info as full
as they can be when when we have
deducted some of the most most
confidential to confused NT ality
concern issues you have a very difficult
language you realize that
I have a number of words I try to avoid
them but then well anyway the two other
cases are very different the absence
case is the case of that placement of
apps on third-party sites what can you
make out of demands as house and this
can be worked for for people also to
enter this market of placing ads on
third-party websites the Android case
may be more interesting because it has
to do with dominance and search when we
all go mobile because this is of course
the only thing that is growing and
growing very fast we all become mobile
we have our smartphones tablets smaller
screens and in the statement of
objection what we're saying is that as
we see it Google has been using Android
which is a very interesting operating
system it's open source a lot of amazing
things can be said about that but then
it has been used to make sure that when
you're open your box then you have the
Google experience on your smartphone and
now of course we're in the process of
going through the Google depends on the
statement of objection and eventually we
will come to a decision okay
one one distinction or at least I think
a lot of Americans perceive a
distinction between US enforcement and
in the you I think this applies both to
mergers and and maybe especially abusive
dominance is the role of competitors so
it's certainly the case that competitors
will show up with complaints before the
Federal Trade Commission or the
Department of Justice but I guess at
least the perception is that they
receive a friendlier hearing when they
will show up in front of DG cop and in
in Brussels do you share that perception
do you think that European antitrust
jurisprudence is less skeptical or gives
more weight to competitor complaints
than in the United States and if so do
you think that's a good thing or a bad
thing
well I don't think our courts
have this bias and since they don't have
the buyers we don't have the bias
because our decisions they go to court
almost with no exception few but almost
with no exception so so we have to
prepare to be heard in court and what
our courts what is of course the
jurisprudence is the evidence the fact
of the case they don't want to hear any
sort of soft feelings that we feel sorry
for you it has no place in a courtroom
so yes of course it's a source of
information of concern to get a case
started but it's not the case of the
competitor it is what happens to the
consumer if this behavior can actually
be proven with the evidence of the case
and and this is what we do and I don't
think there is any problem in listening
to complainants taking on board the
evidence they come with it's our
responsibility to make sure that we get
the evidence right you mentioned
consumer welfare and some my last
question or next to last so you know we
live in obviously very challenging times
times for tremendous change political
change both in the US and the EU brexit
and the EU the Crump election obviously
signs of turmoil in the United States
and and and those the sense that big
business or high tech has not produced
the kind of benefits that people would
have liked to have seen or at least they
haven't been shared fairly across
society has led to calls on both sides
of the Atlantic for competition to play
more active role and remediating those
problems you said in talking about the
Apple decision I think that part of the
motivation there was that Europeans were
angry I think was the word you used
about what's happened and about the role
played by kind of big high tech
companies earning billions in profits
and not paying taxes in the u.s. we've
had this phenomenon of what some people
have referred to as hipster antitrust
the notion that the antitrust ought to
expand and some of our we call them
progressives here our senators have you
know come up with the notion that
antitrust ought to play much broader
role in kind of pursuing social justice
so I read some of the things you've
written previously and you spoke to this
issue from the podium here tighten that
and apologize for the broad question but
but in that kind of broad context you
know how do you see the limits of
antitrust
how far can antitrust go to helping to
pursue these kind of social justice
objectives and what are the hard limits
where it just needs to step back and say
that's not our not archon not ours to
solve well for us we are obliged by by
our laws by our treaty and and those
political choices were taking a long
long time ago 60 years ago and and this
is our mandate and I think it is very
very important to stick to that mandate
because even though a lot of competence
is with the European Commission it's
it's very it's a very powerful tool I
think anyone who has been doing a little
good yourself know that just because you
have a wonderful hammer not everything
is a nail I know firsthand from you
wouldn't want to see my walls so you
definitely have to know the limitations
of antitrust because there are
democratically elected institutions who
have their responsibility and I think
it's I think it's a good thing because
otherwise you completely D legitimize
what we do you know analytical work in
in murders in a castle investigation
looking into a case of misuse of
dominant position if we start to pour
other things down that
hot and that I think is important and
the other thing is that we also try to
be precise to say well when we take a
decision
it's about assertion behavior a certain
behavior that may be illegal because
most companies also have produced
wonderful things I can remember what it
was like to try to find something on the
internet before we had search engines
you'd hardly try because you had to get
the full address completely right
otherwise just forget about it the
innovation produced by some of the
companies well they have changed our
societies they have changed our lives
these are amazing innovations and this
is this is why they are successful if I
think of you er ask any European why do
you Google things why do you have a
Facebook account let's say it works it's
wonderful I like it they would never
come up with the answer that it's
because it's an American company maybe
the opposite even well thank you for all
of those great answers and now we do
have an opportunity for the audience I
think the first hand I saw was right
here wait for a microphone it's on its
way and introduce yourself please oh
hello commissioner my name is Don Baker
former spent 10 years and antitrust
enforcement at the Justice Department
and I want to ask you about these fines
in other words we in this country
tend to look at big fines as something
that we impose on conduct that's
unmitigated you know there's no
justification for it
per se illegal and we limit it pretty
much to a cartel kind of activity in
Europe you're levying record fines like
against conduct that in in a way falls
more within a rule of reason namely
priorities and things like this and by
contrast in this country
we we get injunctive relief
maybe structure a relief against
monopolies but we don't we don't hammer
them with with big fines and I just
wondered whether you have any reaction
to that kind of issue and concern well I
never sort of had the line of thinking
that we are hammering big companies we
are punishing illegal behavior because
you can be you can be big in Europe very
very very big you can grow enormous
market shares if consumers like your
products and the level of fines recently
is more a reflection of the size of the
companies because we have a set of
guidelines to say what to take into
consideration turnover duration sort of
the the depths of the illegal behavior
and that of course we follow in order
for people to know what they would get
themselves into if they Castle is a
product or or misuse the dominant
position so so obviously this this is
important for us I don't know the the
differences in any detail between the
two jurisdictions but what I can see is
that even with the the differences it
still allows us to work very closely
together what is different is treated
differently but where things are the
same i I also do hope that companies
find that they get more or less the same
treatment no no yes ok can I follow up
on that because it raises that's a
fabulous question Don and the but so we
have a way of imposing big fines on big
corporations that violate section two we
do it through private litigations I'm
reminded that I think I maybe have this
wrong but I think son Warren four
billion dollars in the
Microsoft case as a result of private
litigation follow-on litigation after
the government's prosecution so in that
context what is the state of private
antitrust litigation in the European
Union and if thinking in the context of
the Google matter for example presumably
some of the competitors who have been
harmed by Google as found by the
Commission presumably some of them would
be pursuing litigation is where does
that stand because it's never been as
big a factor in the EU as it has been in
the US now it it hasn't and it's only
very recently that our legislation has
come into effect for private damages and
now the last member states are just in
the process of making it also national
legislation we're seeing sort of the
first private damages sort of coming out
but it's is way too early to have any
kind of prognosis as to how will this
define the future the very basic idea
and it was a cause by my predecessor was
to say well if you also can serve for go
for private damages the deterrent effect
will be much bigger because we haven't
had this before but we have seen the
effects in other jurisdictions right we
had another question here
hi my name's Matt Miller I'm with
Capital Group but we run the American
Funds family of mutual funds and I'm
curious the general privacy data
regulation which is taking effect I
believe in May in Europe do you expect
that that will impact the business
models of the large tech firms through
what I've seen is discussion of
different opt-in or consent provisions
and how might that impact your own work
in the competition spear any thoughts on
that well as you're suggesting this is
not my portfolio this is in the hands of
my my colleague Vera Yoruba but
obviously this is for us very important
a lot of work has gone into making new
privacy rules they come into effect may
next year and the main benefit is that
you get one set of rules for the entire
European Union
there are some things that are new the
right to give be forgotten portability
of your data but basically it sort of
creates the benefit of having one set of
rules I think to some degree because my
nature sort of a glass-half-full nature
it can be very beneficial because if
businesses take this on board maybe also
to some degree to offer privacy by
design it can sort of recreate or
reconnect with users I think the last
time Europeans were asked four out of
five set we feel that we are absolutely
have no control of our personal data and
and I think that poses a risk to all the
benefits that can come from Big Data so
if this can be a push to say well we
will make it more accessible more
understandable so that you know what we
what you're doing and rules are simpler
you don't have to relate to as a
business to 28 different ways of doing
this then I think it can be beneficial
both on the business side of things
and on the user side of things this
gentleman my name is Ollie Breeland I'm
a reporter with the hill newspaper the
question I had was about how White House
circuit officials had reportedly
discussed making companies like Google
and Facebook public utilities
I was curious to get your take on this
argument and see if you're amenable to
it
Thanks
we have a very high bar for that public
utility or essential facility as we
would call it the obvious examples would
be sewers railroads over the tracks that
kind of thing because the test would be
that it is no economically doable to do
a parallel structure that it's
prohibitive in its nature
and and so far we have not found that
when it comes to the digital part of our
economy they still find that well some
of these structures and some of these
networks it is not the economy that
prevents you from doing something
similar so this is this is why I think
this discussion has been slightly
different in Europe I mean follow up on
that again so there has been discussion
about Big Data as an essential facility
if I take those two words and put them
together and and the with the with the
proposal not so much being one of public
utility regulation but rather mandated
sharing of some sort and I think your so
ago the Commission issued
I had a consultation on some of these
questions where did that come out and
what is the current thinking and kind of
the need for companies that whether it's
a Google or a Facebook have unique big
data datasets or arguably allegedly
unique big data datasets
what is the thinking of whether they
should be required under some
circumstances to share those with
potential competitors well we try to to
make things complicated by saying that
you cannot discuss big data just as big
data because there are many many many
different kinds of data on the one hand
side you have data that is not to be
replicated that has a very long duration
that effectively can serve as a as an
asset that can foreclose competitors
from entering your market the other hand
side you have data which is easily
recollected the duration is very short
it's very open for competitors to get
the same or more data and then of course
you have all complex situations in
between we've had a few cases not with
us but for instance the French national
competition Authority they ordered I
think what was their old electricity
incumbent who used to have a monopoly to
share some of their customer data with
competitors in order to do sort of
add-on sales for those customers who
were buying electricity because you
couldn't get this data any other way but
but that being said I think it is it is
very important to keep this conversation
complicated because otherwise we sort of
just close down I think a lot of the
opportunities in data when it comes to
health transportation environment
preventing all kinds of things that we
don't want in our societies but
obviously we also prepare ourselves as I
mentioned the Microsoft LinkedIn case to
look into these questions
also in some detail to see if the
question of data and the form it takes
will be a commutation problem so many
hands what a week to stay in this realm
is gonna be the lucky row today
Commissioner can you give us some more
details on the foreign investments
screen that the Commission is
considering and whether or not you think
the u.s. is cepheus model is something
that could be adopted in Europe yes we
have we have exactly been looking into
other models because we see that the US
as this kind of screening I think Canada
has it as well we found it in Japan some
member states already have FDI screening
in different forms and I think since
world trade and also investment is
developing quite fast these years as I
see it it becomes more qualified more
based on a mutual trust and building up
relationships when it comes to different
ways of regulating issues that take your
interest but I think it is very
important that we have this element of
reciprocity that if if you can buy
things with me I can buy things with you
and it is completely legitimate to say
well we would like to have access to
consider if this is not against what we
could call public order I know this is a
rather broad concept but anyway and for
us it has been important as well again
not to sort of just pour it in the
merger analysis pops because that would
just complicate things there but to keep
it as a separate instruments now to be
discussed with member states I think the
proposal is to be tabled if it hasn't
been tabled very very recently if we'll
take one last question we'll go right
here in the front row
Lu Gagliano
independent consultant the question I
have is how do you look at it contracts
that governments give to corporations in
valuate the question of is that a fair
contract or not given the fact that that
government whether it's Ireland or any
other member of the commission of the
european group has its own
responsibility to manage its own affairs
with so how do you how do you really not
step on their kind of ability to run
their own country well we have been been
looking into and this has been going on
for for quite some time
a number of the cases we're started with
my predecessor and part of the work when
it comes to fiscal state a go all the
way back to Mario Monti so it's a
long-standing tradition and in our court
have said very precisely that we have a
responsibility to control state aid no
matter the form it takes
it could be cash it could be a fiscal
benefit it could be building a lot it
can be a a loan with a variable interest
rate and in the fiscal state aid cases
we've been looking at the schemes but
also tax rulings and when we look into
the tax rulings they are by nature
selective because this is for just one
company and they're not available to
anyone else and then of course we see
well does this give a selective
advantage in the way that things are set
up and this is our test is there
selective advantages here the Irish are
perfectly welcome to have a corporate
level of Taxation of twelve and a half
percent as well as they in Luxembourg
are perfectly it's perfectly legal for
them to have I think twenty eight so you
find varied corporate tax rates but our
test is if it's for you
not for everyone else some of the
schemes that we have found has been
schemed to say well this is for
multinationals only but not for
standalone businesses as the scheme in
Belgium and on the other hand side we
have found schemes in other countries
that were set up to promote national
businesses to the disadvantage of
multinational businesses and those of
course we have dealt with as well and in
the same way to say well you cannot do
that you have to make sure that's the
way you use your freedom to do your own
taxation that it's done with the level
playing field we're gonna let that be
the last comment level playing field
level playing for beautiful
[Applause]